the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to tell you my
theory about the possibility of a new
red wedding in the upcoming season this
year will take a while so just sit back
relax and enjoy it
okay let's start with all details or we
could call it the events that are going
to lead to the brand-new wedding let's
begin in season six
Cersei pulled off one of the greatest
character massacres ever and then after
her last child son Tom and it committed
suicide
Cersei claimed the Iron Throne now the
church is ruling and no matter of the
nurses arrival Cersei will try to keep
your own as long as she can with any
possible help she can get
which she needs more than ever and to
get help which she desperately needs
sure she will need to find new Ally's
which could be hard mostly because of
Services Act because of her using
wildfire to almost extinct house Tyrell
along with all innocent people
however leaked photos have already
confirmed Lannisters new ally in the
upcoming season which is going to be
randyll Tarly by this act randyll Tarly
will get his place in the small council
but it is not wise Lucy wanting him as
her ally sir she doesn't want his great
ideas sir she wants his army and it's
the only reason of these two becoming
the alleys as we have already seen from
the photos the result of that alliance
is going to be Jaime Lannister leading
Lannisters army along with Randall and
de cantar leading their Tarly army
they're going to march of Highgarden and
also from the photos we've seen the
outcome of that battle which will result
the chain isn't arles victory that is
not surprising at all Jamie Randall will
have numbers
devil outnumber Tyrells and both Jamie
and Randall have a lot of military
experience particularly randyll Tarly
who is known as one of the best battle
commanders in Seven Kingdoms until the
last week it seems that services only
ally is going to be randyll Tarly as I
said only until the last week from
leaked photos which were taken at a
shooting set at plaza de Santa Maria the
so during rages first appearance in
season 7 filming set along with your
ants and snakes as we can see yara
Illyrian taining will be captured after
urine destroys our fleet and will parade
through the streets of King's Landing
with
could be considered as the biggest
spoiler for the upcoming season from
like photos we could see your own region
on his horse which is decked out in
great-looking faceplate leading yarn
chains to the streets full of King's
Landing citizens Kerrville coming their
new hero euron greyjoy Yara is not the
only one who is going to parade through
the streets of King's Landing
they're also captured delirious and
ain't her daughter tying these scenes in
which urine is parading with his
prisoners will present urines parading
through the streets of King's Landing
parading all the way to the red keep
at this point it's boring for you to
know that Jaime with Lannister army
along with Randall and historic army
we'll get ambushed while they are
marching home with carriages full of
good solid from Highgarden on their way
home they're going to be ambushed by
Daenerys riding drogon along with her
Dothraki horde after this defeat tarlyn
army will be weak why Lannister army we
can say it's going to be weak but it
won't be powerful as it once had been at
this point Cersei will be desperate
there are enemies all around her and her
ally will be lost
while her army won't be powerful enough
to destroy all of our enemies that's the
moment in which urn is coming to King's
Landing after he successfully defeated
Yara along with sand snakes that's the
moment in which you are no hunter
complaining parading with his prisoners
and is going to pledge his army and our
own fleet to Cersei but in return Cersei
will have to marry him similar deal as
he had for Daenerys
that's the deal with her she will accept
let's deal which will bring her hopes
hopes that Ryan is going to last a
little bit longer that's the deal which
Cersei knows she has to accept or
otherwise her Ryan is over next what is
going to happen is the same from Dragon
pit in which Roman characters will
attend and by the way it's confirmed on
that we can call a meeting 17 major
characters are going to attend which
makes these scenes having a big role in
season 7 and the outcome of the meeting
which is going to be organized by the
inheritors in favour to show all the
Lords the real threat that all of them
are facing in favour to unite their
armies to have a chance against the
undead army is going to have a great
importance for the events to come in
season 8
considering that most probable this
scene is going to be released in season
7 finale while all the lords and
powerful people are going to
agree with Daenerys and will agree to
unite all of their armies all but Cersei
Cersei won't consider the situation as
everyone else
Cersei will welcome the undead army in
her opinion the White Walkers along with
their white horde are going to defeat
all of our enemies which would only
benefit her
according to League plot Jaime will come
to Cersei and ask her for her permission
to lead Lannister army to the north to
join the great battle to join all the
other armies but Cersei refused his
request along with telling him her
opinion about the undead army which I've
already told you a few moments ago
artery Jaime is going to be speechless
Jaime won't believe what she just said
furthermore battery mine that moment sir
she'll also announce to Jaime that she
is going to marry urine in a few days
meanwhile according to the plot Jaime
will before search his confession
already meet with Tyrion and Davos
meeting in which Tyrion is going to try
to convince his brother Jaime to join
him to join the we can call it good side
but Jamie is going to refuse with
statement that he is a Lannister and it
he would never betray his sister well
that's Jamie's opinion before knowing
sir she's opinion by the undead army and
before Circe's announcement about
marrying urine as a result of all of
that Jaime will decide to we can call it
to help save the world
Jaime will kill once again the one who
he was supposed to protect with his own
life but also Jaime will once again save
a lot of innocent lives
Jaime is going to kill Cersei let's get
back on the day in which Cersei is going
to get killed
let's get back on the events that will
happen earlier that day
am i teary Jaime disappointed by sir his
opinion we'll think about leaving King's
Landing and support the living side with
his experience in leading army that same
day Cersei will get married to your own
Greyjoy while Jamie will finish his
preparations to leave King's Landing
just before Jamie leaves King's Landing
he's going to feel the need to see
Cersei once again and to tell her that
he is leaving and he's going to support
all inside well sir she won't show her
feelings furthermore by my theory Cersei
will mock him sir she will tell him that
she doesn't need him anymore
that she now has her husband husband who
has the biggest fleet in the army to
support her Jaime frustrated by those
Cersei statements encouraged by the fact
that she
urine wounds in their arm is the Nord
Army is that the link side desperately
needs Jamie will decide to kill her he
details to strangle Searcy to death
along with killing urine most likely
with someone else's help
after that Jamie will join the we can
call it war between life and death
along with Lannister army if this theory
comes true which I truly believe it
would fulfill the prophecy of Maggy the
Frog the prophecy which we have seen and
flashback in season 5 let me remind you
in that flashback Cersei stole that she
can ask questions from the witch of
which to answer she already came true
first search this question for manga
buzz when will I married the prince if
you're not introduced with who the
prince is in this question it was
regular triggering the prince for whom
sir she was promised answers this
question mega answered with never you
will buy the king as you already know
this first prophecy came true as we know
Robert Baratheon killed Prince Rhaegar
and also became the king along with
marrying Cersei which makes this first
part of prophecy being nothing else but
the truth second search this question
was were looking at now hello children
on which man responded with the king
will have 20 and you will help 3 as we
all already know this also came true
Robert Baratheon had a lot of bastard
children particularly he had 20 of them
well sir she had three with her brother
Jaime also in Maggie's answer she said
gold will be their crowns and gold their
shrouds which also came true both Cersei
son Joffrey and Tommen were crowned
kings while in the books
woman in Dorne crown searched his
daughter Myrcella as a queen while the
part of Maggie's answer which contains
gold their shrouds means that all of
search the children will die and as we
know it also came true
Joffrey Myrcella were both murdered and
both of them are shown in golden funeral
garb well tomm and committed suicide by
jumping out of the window if you didn't
know it is Tommen was wearing golden
jacket in that scene well sir she was
leaving the witch stent may get older
one final thing she told and when your
tears for drowned you the valonqar shall
wrap his sense about your Pelt what
wrote and showed the life from you in
the cavalry language of the east wall
incur means
brother so the exact prediction that
Maggie told the Circe was that her
younger brother real killer and if you
don't know Cersei and Jaime are twins
but Cersei is older a couple of minutes
if this theory of mind comes showing the
upcoming season
it will also fulfill the prophecy of
which Maggie of which who predicted
almost all sources future and all that
came true all except one final
prediction until now we've had red
wedding in which King Robb Stark was
betrayed and brutally killed along with
his wife Elise and Aaron were child
Rob's mother lady Catelyn the other
lords along with Tommen in the camps
including Rob's dire wolf then we've had
the proper wedding in which King Joffrey
Baratheon was poisoned by Lord Petyr
Baelish and Lady Olenna Tyrell his own
wedding during the wedding feast what
color do you think will label this
wedding into your mind of course if it
comes true don't you this point believe
to which Magus predictions and also let
me know your opinion on this theory of
mine in the comment section down below
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and yeah see you next time peace
[Music]